[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
brand new attack on Titan video in this
video we will be talking about three of
the biggest unsolved mysteries in the
attack on Titan manga so naturally there
will be manga spoilers proceed with
caution the three mysteries that we will
be addressing in this video include
number one the 140 v Kings ideology and
why he decided to move the capital of
Elvia to the island of Paradiso in the
first place
abandoning many of his fellow LDN on the
continent in the process even though he
knew that this would lead to them being
oppressed by the Marlin mystery number 2
is the key Eggers true intentions which
I believe are different than they appear
to be at first glance and the latest
manga chapter actually gives us some
important clues about this and finally
four mystery number three we'll be
looking at probably the single most
mysterious scene in the entire manga a
scene in which the owl
Ehren Kruger tells Grisha that he must
protect Mikasa and Armin even though
Armin Mikasa and Aaron have not even
been born yet at this point before we
get into it I want to thank everybody
for all your support on the channel
don't worry even though the attack on
Titan anime finished airing a few months
ago we are still going to have a regular
attack on Titan content on this channel
we're going to be looking at the new
manga chapters as they come out and of
course 1 season 3 comes up we are going
to be on top of that too so be sure to
stay tuned to anime uproar and if you're
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
valve also if you want to have all the
latest updates first be sure to follow
us on twitter at anime out drawer and we
also just created a Twitter poll where
we are asking you guys what type of
content you want to see on this channel
in the future so be sure to check us out
on Twitter and follow us and vote in the
poll to let us know and now if you are
psyched and ready to go be sure to go
beast mode on that like button and let's
get into it
speaking of beast mode let's start with
leek Yeager and what he says in Chapter
95 of the attack on Titan manga while
talking to the other LD and
for years about launching another attack
on parodies with the help of the Tiber
family who are the possessors of the
Warhammer Titan Zeke says the following
recent battles have made it even more
clear to all that conventional weapons
will outperform Titan weaponry in the
near future in other words it will not
be long before LDN to lose their
tactical value in the same conversation
Peake also says something important when
she states that even if the plan to
retake the founder succeeds I feel like
that wouldn't be enough to balance out
the rest of the world's historical
feelings about LD and given how bad it's
gotten now these statements are
important for the following reason
Marlay and the rest of the world hates
LDS because they fear their potential to
become Titans
and they consider them to be spawn of
the devil and therefore evil subhuman
and dangerous despite the terrible ways
in which marlott resell the ends forcing
them to live in internment zones forcing
them to turn into Titans to fight
Marley's enemies and even brutally
killing innocent children as was the
case with grisha's sister the reason
that Marley hasn't exterminated all of
the LDS yet is because the LDS are
useful their Titan powers have been used
by Marley to gain dominance over their
enemies and establish a powerful Empire
but the situation is now changing recent
advancements in weapons technology have
made the Titans less useful and as we
learned in Chapter 92 even the armor
titans armor can now be pierced by
modern weapons so what does this mean
once LVN lose their tactical value as
Zeke said their Titan Power will no
longer be needed and as peak observes
the hatred for LD ends all over the
world has gotten so bad that even taking
back the founding Titan would probably
not convince the world to hate them any
less this means that once tightened
power no longer holds value the Marlins
and the other nations of the world will
likely try to exterminate all ldm lVN's
are both hated and feared because of
their ability to transform into titans
and they are considered dangerous spawn
of the devil closer to monsters than
actual human this fear is confirmed
directly in Chapter 95 when we are told
that the world is now saying that there
is no need to apply the
of human rights to Albion which is of
course a threat to the existence of the
entire LDN race these statements confirm
that the rest of the world seems to hate
LD ends just as much if not even more
than the Marlins do since male keeps
using them as weapons against other
countries and it is already being said
that ldiots don't deserve basic human
rights meaning that they are less than
human and once a group of people are
stripped of human rights and labeled as
subhuman and monstrous it is very
possible that the next step will be
genocide it has happened multiple times
in history once
ldiots have lost their value to male it
is very likely that they will attempt to
exterminate all LDN to keep them from
ever becoming a threat again in the
future Zeke is clearly aware of this
possibility but he claims at least in
this conversation which he knows is
being monitored by the Marlin officials
that's the best way to protect the alien
race is to prove themselves as loyal
Marlins by getting the power of the
farming Titan back from parodies but of
course knowing how much Marlin paid the
aliens and how they treat them this
seems very naive Zeke scores an
off-the-charts 11 out of 10 in
intelligence so I cannot see how he
could possibly believe this when even
peek is trying to say that nothing the
audience do can change the world's
opinion of them we will get back to this
point a little later but now let's talk
about the 145th Kings ideology we know
that about 100 years ago the 145th King
abandoned mainland aldia and moved the
capital well do two parodies he then
built the three walls around the island
with the use of a huge number of
Colossus Titans filled the audience that
came with him inside erase their
memories of the world beyond the walls
and warned all Outsiders that if they
interfered he would unleash the many
colossal Titans in the wall to flatten
the entire world those ldiots who did
not follow the 145th came to paradise
were defeated in the great titan war by
the Marlins and subsequently subjugated
and oppressed now what could have
possibly led the 145th King to abandon a
huge portion of his own people to such a
terrible faith and to isolate himself on
a remote island
what's more why is it that every other
member of the row
family who inherits the founding Titan
power also inherits the Kings ideology
once they gain the Kings memories they
instantly come to support his decision
and they do nothing to help the LVN
outside the walls even kind-hearted
people like Freda wreaths refused to
budge from the 145th Kings ideology once
they inherit his memories this is one of
the biggest mysteries in attack on Titan
in my opinion but I think that I finally
have an answer
I believe that the 145th King moved the
LDS capital to Paradise and build the
walls in order to save the alien race as
a whole I think he foresaw that
eventually technology would advance to
the point that Titan power would have
little value and he realized that once
that point came the nations of the world
would decide to exterminate all ldm the
king must have thought that the only way
to save the LVN race was to isolate a
portion of it inside a giant fortress on
a remote island and to threaten the
entire world to stay away if he hadn't
done this the lVN's would eventually
have become defenseless against modern
technology and they would all have been
exterminated once Titan power lost its
tactical value and that is exactly what
is happening now Titan Power is losing
its value in the face of modern weapons
LD ants are hated by the entire world
and they are being stripped of human
rights setting the stage for a genocide
but the question is how could the 145th
King have foreseen the exact scenario
that is happening now over 100 years
later this is where the future memories
come in as mentioned earlier probably
the single most mysterious scene in the
entire manga is a scene in Chapter 89 in
which the owl
Ehren Kruger tells Grisha that he must
protect Mikasa and Armin even though
Armin Mikasa and Aaron have not been
born yet Aaron saw this conversation as
a memory that he inherited through the
attack Titan power which was first
possessed by the owl and then by Grisha
now some might think that Aaron's
memories were getting jumbled here and
that he was not remembering the
conversation between Grisha and the owl
correctly but what if these memories
were in fact real
what if Titan shifters can actually see
the
future we know that all aliens are
connected through invisible pathways
that are not bound by physical space so
what if they are not bound by time
either
what if Titan shifters not only inherit
memories of the past from previous
Titans but also future memories from
future Titan shifters what is the 145th
King through the founding Titan power
received memories of the future in which
he saw that modern technology would
surpass Titan power and that this would
lead to the extinction of the entire LDN
race what if he moved the capital to
paradise and built the walls around it
to prevent that very thing from
happening and what is the reason that
all members of the royal family who
inherit the founding Titan power
suddenly adopt the 145th Kings ideology
is because they see those future
memories as well once they inherit the
power they suddenly realize that if they
leave parodies and try to help the
audience on the continent they will
inevitably bring about the destruction
of the entire LDN race
this would explain why a kind-hearted
person like Freda Reed would not try to
help the LD end on the continent he and
all the other holders of the founding
Titan with royal blood are faced with an
extremely difficult choice they can
either try to help the other LD ends and
destroy the entire LDN race in the
process or abandon the other Albion in
order to preserve the alien race as a
whole we know that the first episode of
the attack on titan anime and the first
chapter of the manga bared the titles to
you in two thousand years or to you two
thousand years from now this title is
never explained but I think it is very
interesting because we know that the
fritz royal bloodline traces its roots
back to amir fritz
nearly two thousand years earlier if our
theory about future memories is correct
and Titan shifters can see into the
future by seeing the memories of future
time shifters then this mysterious title
would finally make sense the title is an
early clue that Titan shifters have
access to memories of future events the
founding Titan power when held by a
member of the royal family can
manipulate the memories of Albion and it
gives the possessor the power to clearly
see the memories of the previous kings
however it is definitely possible that a
member
the royal bloodline with this power
could not just see into the past or even
a few years into the future but far into
the future maybe even 2000 years into
the future and finally this brings us to
the true intentions of Zeke Yeager the
current holder of the Beast Titan power
the son of Grisha and deny ager and a
member of the royal bloodline through
his mother we know that as a child
Grisha and Deena wanna sneak to
infiltrate the Marlon regime by
volunteering to become a warrior receive
the power of a Titan shifter and then
use that power to help the LDS
restorationist in their fight against
marlane however the young Zeke betrayed
his parents and gave them up to the
Malayan authorities which led to his
mother being turned into a Titan and his
father nearly sharing the same face
before being rescued by the owl now
while we can believe that the very young
Zeke betrayed his parents because he was
naive and came to believe Marley
propaganda that was being forced onto
him on a daily basis I find it much
harder to believe that the adults League
whose intelligence is known to be 11 out
of 10 would keep buying into Marland
propaganda and believe that ldiots can
expect a bright future under Malayan
rule I find it much more likely that
Zeke now fully realizes the truth soon
modern weapons will surpass Titan
technology meaning that LD ins will lose
their tactical value and this will
eventually result in the genocide and
extermination of all LDN once there is
no more reason to keep them around
we know that in chapter 83 of the manga
Zeke says to his half brother Aaron that
he will someday come to save him since
Zeke only has one more year left as a
Titan shifter he wants to return to
paradise as soon as possible but why
exactly does he want to return I believe
that Zeke is definitely intelligent
enough to realize that LD ins faced
extinction in the near future I believe
that he wants to save the LDN race
including Aaron and just like the 145th
king who was willing to abandon some
ldiots to save the race of the whole
week is prepared to kill some LDS to
save the rest I think that he
understands the ideology of the 145th
king and the royal family but he sees
beyond their ideology as well Vic took
part in marlane military missions that
involves dropping Titans from the air
into
enemy territory and he knows that soon
enough technology will advance to the
point that even the walls on paradise
will not be able to stop those who want
to kill the aliens if they simply decide
to drop bombs out of aircraft onto the
island I believe that Zeke wants to
coordinate power but not to give it to
the Malayan government rather he wants
to use it to somehow ensure the survival
of the LDN race
the reason Zeke is so desperate to have
all the warriors sent on another mission
to paradise is because he plans to make
his move there he will most likely try
to convince the other shifters that they
cannot count on Marlay to protect them
and that they have to take their future
into their own hands we can't be sure
what his exact strategy will be yet he
could plan to keep the walls up but
introduce modern technology to parodies
in order to ensure that the LVN there
can protect themselves from outside
threats or he might be planning to
somehow use the coordinate power to
finally release the wall Titans and use
them to take out Marlay before
technology advances to the point where
titan power is no longer useful at any
rate I think that Zeke is planning
something that no one else is expecting
he knows how poorly the moorlands treat
the aliens he knows that there is no
future for the audience with the
moorlands in power but he also sees the
flaws in the ideology of the 145th
King and I believe that Zeke is planning
to divide both sides by putting an
entirely different plan into motion and
now I want to hear your thoughts what do
you think do you agree with our theory
about Titan shifters being able to see
future memories and how this relates to
the 145th Kings ideology do you think
that Zeke is up to something and if so
what do you think he's actually going to
do let us know down below if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more be
sure to go beast mode on that like
button
and if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell as always thank you
all so much for watching and until next
time see our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]